قدمت طلبا رسميا للامين العام للامم
المتحده بانه يضعها على جدول اعماله من
اجل تطبيق هذين القرارين بمعنى اولا
تطبيقهم فيما يتعلق بحقنا في فلسطين فيما
يتعلق بحق اللاجئين وفيما يتعلق بعضويه
اسرائيل وهي
عضويه غير قانونيه الان اسرائيل منذ دخلت
الامم المتحده الى الان ليست عضوا رسميا
وليس سعود والقانونيه بناء على هذين
القرنين اللذين لم
تلتزم بهما ولما طيب ولكن عندما قدمت
فخامه الرئيس هذا الطلب قدمت على اساس
ورقه تريد ان ترفعها الان في هذه الفتره
الحساسه او لا ان فعلا في اليات يمكن ان
تطبقي عندك امل
على اساس يعني يقوم الامين العام للامم
المتحده بواجبه
في
الجمعيه العامه ونحن من جانبنا سنتقدم
للجمعيه العامه بطلب تنفيذهم يعني لن
نتركها ايضا للامين العام وانما نحن كعضاع
مراقبين ومن حقن ان نقدم طلب ان نقدم طلب
تنفيذ هذين القرارين مش بس مجرد انه نحن
لا بدنا نطلب تنفيذهم
اللي ضربنا على مدى 70 سنه 74 سنه مش راح
ينصفنا هذه الايام الشيء الاخر وبصراحه
الذي يقف حجر عثره في طريق تنفيذ القرارات
وبالذات قرارات
الاسرائيل في
رفضها لكلها عدم الالتزام بهذه القرارات
يعني
اطالب امريكا
نتحدث بهذه القضايا لعل وعسى ياتي وقت
يتغير الموقف الامريكي يتغير ان شاء الله